hello and thank you for joining on this
broadcast training and competency
assessment presentation my name is
Ashley Wathan I am joining you from
covance laboratories in Madison
Wisconsin United States also joining me
on the call and to give this
presentation is Marianne vas binder she
is currently the director for global
training in the office of animal welfare
ethics and strategy at glaxosmithkline
and I serve as a senior clinical
veterinarian here at covance
laboratories so today I'm an outline of
our presentation what it will include is
a overview of training some brief
definitions and some discussions about
how the definitions differ and a
baseline on those and then we'll be
talking about some training programs to
specifics with some examples from both
of our programs which hopefully will
give you an idea through our two
programs how things work and then lastly
we'll cover methods for globalization on
both of our companies covance and GSK
are both global and so working to
globalize our methods in training so
first I just want to talk about
different types of training that may be
included within a training program so of
course there are lectures and type a
didactic type training session in a
classroom setting and these could be
small groups or very large groups
depending on your setting also online
modules these are really helpful if you
want to provide alignment of messages
across global programs which is
something that we definitely consider
here both at Kobe on st. at GSK hands-on
workshops are really helpful for
technical training techniques that
require some skill and then one-on-one
training a lot of times you especially
the technical training a one-to-one
setting might be ideal when you really
need to display something that a person
will perform taking that one to one
method might be the ideal way I'm so
here at covance we do a variety of
different types we usually incorporates
multiple of these types of training so
we'll start with the lectures and then
we will I don't usually go to a hands-on
workshop i'm using training animals at
covance usually we use the online
modules through our i learn program to
do trainings or refreshers on things
like good laboratory practices I'm
Environmental Health and Safety and
programs and other things like that and
again online is really great for when
you want to get the same message across
to multiple sites other modes that you
might hear or use include podcasts
newsletters or small discussion groups
so one thing that we utilized a lot with
the advent of the new guide was the hola
podcast and webinars that they provided
so it was a great way for our technical
staff veterinarians and our aya cook
members to get that cee and through
those through those free podcasts that
they provided so next I'm going to go
through some different training material
formats so when you talk about training
standards and usually there's a
consideration of local versus global and
these might vary and some things might
be similar but there may be some
differences as well so also something
that we notice here at covance is that
the training material formats are really
driven by the size of the facility so
Madison is one of our larger facilities
across the globe for this type of
environment again like I mentioned we
will usually start with a lecture with a
large group of people in a didactic
setting and we also use a
and a lot of those online modules just
to keep things standard and to
disseminate the information through a
large group of people where they receive
the same type of content consistently
for a smaller scale facility lots of
times makes more sense to do a
one-on-one type of training and it could
be that there are you know there might
just be smaller number of trainers in
the facility so that's a limitation and
then number of trainees that they manage
could also be smaller so one-on-one
training a lot of times for the smaller
facilities makes a lot more sense um
next consideration is the type of skill
being trained so again we can use those
online trainings for things that are
regulatory in nature and don't require a
lot of technical skill but for bio
methods which would include technical
skills such as oral gavage subcutaneous
injections things like that really need
a hands-on component in addition to the
didactic training this is again where
our trainers have the possibility to
work with the trainees show them how to
do the technique and then walk them
through the steps hands-on so another
consideration with training material
formats would be addressing diverse
learning styles so we try to use
multiple training methods for each task
we never trained just using one method
we never just trained in a lecture
setting it is also it is always more
than one training format and again we
usually start em in the lecture setting
and kind of move through and becoming
more towards a hands-on and a one-to-one
setting so next um a question that we
came up with when we were discussing our
training programs well see this should
be providing the training and this is a
good question and it can vary from
organization to organization
and depend on your setting so I'm just
going to go through how covance manages
these things so training teams how did
our the trainer selected how are the
trainers trained so what we do in the
Kobe on setting is that trainers are
identified from our senior technical
staff they have a broad-based knowledge
including all range of species
techniques and have also shown a proven
track record of high level of
performance so when we select these
trainers to become part of our core
training group they then undergo
additional training within that group on
how to techniques for delivering
training to new employees so they may be
very skilled and have expertise in their
technical training but they may not have
that piece about how do they provide the
training to others so that is something
that we address once they've been
accepted into the core training group
which i think is very important
consideration next question is what
about post-approval monitoring for the
training program so currently there is
not here at covance there's not a formal
and what is would be considered your
traditional post-approval monitoring
however we do have a lot of regular
monitoring through other means we have
supervisors managers and since we are a
DLP compliant facility a quality
assurance department do to those glp
requirements so we use them as our
informal post-approval monitoring method
um again in an academic type of a
setting and those experiences I have
seen a lot more the formal post-approval
monitoring for these types of things but
because we are in this glp environment
it varies a little bit differently so
free for those of you who are in an
academic setting a more formal
post-approval monitoring may be more
ideal for monitoring your training also
if there are issues that are found that
can be traced back to training
deficiencies or lapses and training
those are addressed and can be you know
identified in address through the
quarter
group or veterinarians have also been
involved to further assess what the
trainers are teaching to the new
employees and to really evaluate those
techniques to see if they need to be
changed or improved also veterinarians
are integrally involved whenever there
are major process changes in the
training program or in our bio method
techniques so again we're looking
towards the training group to to make
those updates but also the veterinary
staff as well so again unlike the
academic setting where there are staff
within the investigators or the labs
that are providing training and really
is different and within our core
training group in our glp studying so we
don't have you know these different
types of labs that are providing the
training we really have that core group
of people and there are occasions layer
and we do have something that might be
outside of the scope of our core
training group and that would require us
to have external experts come into the
facility to train our either our
technical staff or investigators or just
perform those techniques for us and so
sometimes we have ophthalmologists that
will come in and do specific techniques
that again fall outside that normal
scope and then lastly veterinarian
involvement so we have veterinarians
that provide training within our groups
on certain animal health and welfare
topics and above and beyond what our
training corps training group provides
this gives some of those of visibility
to the veterinarians so the technique
technicians know who we are and again we
can really speak as a subject matter
experts on animal health and welfare so
we do that as well Thank You Ashley I
now wanted to transition into talking
about how do training programs talk
about their programs one of the things
that has to be done when group when
groups of people are are working on
training programs is they need to agree
definitions there's an export paper
there was published
so it looks like we're having some
technical difficulties unfortunately
getting marianna so um I'll continue on
with some definitions to give kind of a
framework about you know when we talk
about these different terms just really
being on the same page so first um
determining competency or what is
competent so confident being competent
is a trainees potential knowledge and
skill so it's whether they are able to
perform and apply knowledge and skills
so it means that the trainee would be
able to demonstrate the knowledge and
ability required to perform a certain
technique or bio method and also
considers personal limitations so this
is just the nuts and bolts a very basic
are they able to perform the skill or
not so an assessment is really a
checklist of points that the trainee
must have the knowledge of or be able to
demonstrate something in a practical
sense to be able to perform a skill so
when you talk about what is competency
assessment it really refers to a whole
process the summative process that takes
that evidence that they've collected
about a Chinese progress over time and
then determining whether a trainee has
achieved the ability to perform a
specific bio method appropriately so
typically a competency assessment is
performed during the training or
immediately after a training session so
this is early on again kind of checking
through these boxes to see I'm the fat
rainy can I have the ability to perform
a specific technique and it also
evaluates whether the task was performed
correctly so proficiency in contrast to
competency is whether a trainee can
consistently and accurately perform the
bio method and so this in my mind goes
kind of one step further than competency
does it's a measure of performance and a
set of observable behaviors so when you
do an assessment of proficiency it's
typically made after the initial
training so the training has the trainee
has had the opportunity to practice
refined newly learned skills and then
could include a step above so measuring
speed and refined accuracy so again a
goal for this proficiency assessment
would be to ensure that the trainee has
not deviated from the correct technique
it is really best that this be performed
by someone other than the original
trainer and what this does is allows for
the minimization of bias and that it
ensures objectivity so again I think
there has been some confusion amongst
talking about competency versus
proficiency and this have been used
interchangeably in the past but there
really is this difference it's kind of a
very fine difference but something to
consider when you talk in your programs
about what are you really measuring are
you doing competency assessments are you
doing proficiency assessments are both
and having those differ there's
something to consider so moving on just
to make this more real-life and
expanding on this with some real life
examples first with the competency
assessment so the example that I've
chosen to use here would be Mouse oral
gavage technique so again in our program
we typically will start with lectures on
the appropriate process our trainees
will also review and read and sign off
on any applicable SOPs related to the
process and then our technical trainers
will move on
a hands-on training setting so when our
facility we use training colony animals
for this purpose and that's where the
trainers will be able to show the
trainees the appropriate technique for
handling an animal the correct hold and
they'll go over measuring for placement
of the kabosh and then we will typically
use saline in the training facility to
do actually install something in the
garage and see if it works so initially
again there's either a one to one or a
one two three and a very small number of
people that will kind of directly
oversight initially so they're really
going through making sure those trainees
have a good understanding of what's
going on and once they kind of feel
comfortable with the process that train
will kind of step back and do more of an
oversight from afar so they might leave
the room and just watch from the window
again providing that oversight but I'm
kind of backing away as the trainees
show progress and through this whole
process the trainer will be evaluating
the techniques and offering any
Corrections so you know they may weigh
in on okay you know you need a little
bit more angle here or a little bit less
restraint and so on just to provide that
constant feedback to the training um
then here in our facility there is a
formal certification process that is
given if a set of minimum criteria are
met so it usually involves two things
the trainee is required to respond
correctly to questions regarding the
technique to show that they understand
the process and then from a technical
standpoint the trainee has to perform
the actual task correctly without error
to then receive that formal
certification so again in this process
we're talking about a competency
assessment so it's normally done as are
being trained and owned just after
they've been recently trained on this
technique so staying with the oral
gavage example but moving towards a
proficiency assessment and how that
would differ and we do ongoing
proficiency assessments
which is after the initial training
competency train has been established so
we already know that the technician has
the ability to perform the oral gavage
so they have been shown to be competent
they have received a certification in a
formal way but we're doing ongoing
provisioning proficiency assessments so
with the oral gavage technique again
with our glp environment we have spot
checks that are performed by both our QA
department and also our supervisors so
these are unannounced observations that
are used to ensure that there are Jennie
ongoing deviations so we really depend
on on these methods of you know again
informal post-approval monitoring to be
watching for any any issues that they
may note and the tech change technicians
are deviating from their from their
procedure so if they are found to have
evidence of deviations they're recorded
and then placed into a centralized
database for being addressed they can be
addressed in a couple of different ways
and the deviations can be addressed by
the supervisor with a simple reminder or
something like that or it could be more
serious where it needs to go to further
training if it's you know a problem
that's identified that is more egregious
than that that person may need to
undergo retraining so also there could
be more assessment done if there are
actual errors noted so if there's a
group of mice that undergo oral gavage
procedure and then are noted to have
oral gavage accidents or esophageal
perforation that would be considered an
error they could look back to that
technician if it's you know a technician
has multiple errors noted then the
supervisor and or training staff or
veterinarians would go in for
reassessment of that technicians
technique again looking to see if their
technique is sound and then there's a
possibility for removing their
certification and requiring the
additional training be performed prior
to performing that task again so
typically if we're going to that
we are withholding that technician from
performing that task until they go
through the training process again and
are we certified and determined by the
trainer they have the ability again so
to go through and perform that task so
then establishing a curriculum within
your training program so again just to
go through a couple of questions and
thoughts talking about how Kobe on some
does these some mandatory versus
elective curriculum and a question that
I came up with was what are potential
outcomes for non-compliance so here at
covance most of our training offerings
are considered to be mandatory and
however there are some specialized
training that individuals can aspire to
attain as they become more proficient in
their technical role this adds a level
of career growth to our positions and
gives them something again to aspire to
to working up to so it's more than their
baseline knowledge that they're
considered to be necessary for their
day-to-day job but again is more of a
specialized training and to maintain
compliance with mandatory training in
our environment there are extensive and
specific training records that are
maintained this again stems from the
fact that we follow the glp requirements
and these specific training records are
reviewed by training staff management
and again our QA department to ensure
that individuals have completed all of
their necessary trainings that there's
not a labs so this may vary a lot
depending on your your situation and
your your company or academic setting
for those individuals that are in more
of an academic setting you wouldn't
necessarily have this glp requirement to
maintain these specific records and have
them be reviewed often so it is
something to consider I think it's very
helpful for us in maintaining these
records in a very rigorous way because
it does allow us to go back
and access that information really
really gives us that information fast at
hand so how r curriculum estab eula
established so here it's over a long
term monk period of time it's generally
incorporating techniques that have been
shown to work well and it's
incorporating multiple different types
of formats as i mentioned to address the
variations in learning styles so those
people that may here to learn better or
see or do incorporating multiple
techniques to address all those
different needs also when curriculum has
changed the core training group and will
typically involve pertinent personnel
which might include our scientific staff
usually includes the veterinarians as
well and anyone that might have
expertise that can weigh in on
establishing new formats so how are the
trainees identified and so how it works
here at covance is that new hires come
in and there's a pretty intensive mostly
didactic training their first two weeks
of their hire date this is part of a
regulated onboarding process and this
initial broad training that's giving
them kind of a basis of you know safety
and the company and really a baseline
knowledge is generally performed in
larger groups all of the new technicians
enter a track upon their hiring which is
either small animal track or a large
animal track then within each track
appropriate training is assigned to them
so if they're learning about large
animals are going to learn about dogs
and non-human primates and potentially
rabbits and then the groups are made
made smaller as they go into their
separate tracks and they're assigned
different trainers who take over those
training those tasks tasks within the
smaller groups
oops and then lastly we are we are
currently involved in developing a
specific policy regarding training which
we hope to roll out this year but again
just to provide an SOP format to
determine what is required for training
how is this implemented and just provide
a more formal policy regarding our
training program so that is currently in
development at this time so next talking
about frequency of retraining so what do
you think about regulations there's a
lot of questions about whether or not
there is a true guidance or requirement
in the regulations for frequency of
retraining my experience it's pretty
nebulous what is required and I've seen
it done a lot of different ways so here
at covance are approaches that for
technical staff that perform bio methods
they maintain their certification as
long as lack of proficiency is not
identified so if they are proficient
over time there wouldn't be any change
in their certification now we do have
scenarios where people choose to leave
the department and their current job
duties and go elsewhere within the
company and then they may return to this
department in the future so typically if
it that's over been over a six-month
time frame where they've left and then
returned they would be required to
retrain if it was less than six months
than they could still maintain that
certification because it hasn't kind of
followed fall falling outside of that
time frame that we would require then we
also do some online refresher trainings
that are required on an annual basis and
again this would be things like
non-human primate herpes be training
other occupational health training and
such as our hearing conservation program
and things like that
um again like I mentioned some programs
do this a little bit differently and
have instituted of frequency of
retraining at a certain time frame so
depending on the task they may require a
one-year retraining or in every three
year retraining however we have such a
high throughput in this environment that
our technicians are performing these
tasks very regularly and in our minds
that really acts to maintain their
certification again as long as they show
that they are maintaining their
proficiency all right so now I'm going
to try to pass over to marry and to talk
about these try to pop over to Mary
Thank You Ashley I think I have control
now I hope it's working for all of us I
wanted to address programs of training
so in for example a large pharmaceutical
company like I work in we have what are
considered global training programs that
are programs administered from site to
site to site and there can be several
sites involved with this and several
cultures involved with it so for example
one of the things we aspire to is making
sure that how we handle and care for
rats and mice in China is the same when
we handle and care for rats and mice in
the United States and in the UK and so
just taking into account the different
cultures and the way that people learn
can be an important part of the program
in some academic institutions there can
be multiple departments that actually
function somewhat like independent
global systems where they work and have
completely different needs for their
training and and have different methods
for for administration and then and so
there's just a lot of different ways
that that organizations can choose to
manage their training I think that
there's a distinct advantage to having
core training groups a group of people
dedicated to delivery of training it's
actually a very useful way to coordinate
and actually find some harmonization in
the way that training is administered
and so core training groups for example
in a medical school where they would
train all the people to do techniques
the same way could be very helpful and
it really helps push the resources and
and then the ability to train
effectively lastly there's another way
that that can be heaven so in our
organization the laboratory animal
sciences group is responsible for
delivery or operationalization of
training where I belong in office of
welfare and strategy and we help
administer what is the global training
program but in situations where
investigators are responsible for the
training for example at some academic
institutions I've worked in there have
been there had not been central core
training groups so the veterinarians and
the investigators are critical piece to
the training of new employees but I
think that as we as we progress there's
an increasing need to help training
programs have some level of expectations
as to what occurs in a training program
and I think it's really important that
these expectations don't mind the hands
of the organization so they can't
deliver deliver the training in the way
that's most needed for for them so
different sites have different
scientific remits they have different
animal models they have different ways
of working and tools and equipment that
they work with so it's very important
that the program is is flexible but but
can be harmonized at GSK we agreed to
harmonize in 2010 and it's been a very
very long road and I can't say that I
think that we've really gotten there yet
with our training programs because we're
still working very hard to understand
what agreed what that agreed system
would look like but I can say that we
sat down and talked about what we would
aspire to in our training program and
those would be things like consistent
training documents for it's possible
quality as a standard of quality for a
program based on some standard minimum
standard an expectation for the
verification of competency of people who
are trained and then a consistent way of
documenting across our programs
realizing that in in GOP environments
it's very natural to perform
documentation but in in the in the
Discovery areas and in the scientific
research organizations there's not a
often not consistency in how that's done
also we aspire to having a learning
commutative practice for the people that
are experts perform that are responsible
for training at each of our sites will
sit on a community that then that then
will provide oversight and guidance and
share common practices so our model for
harmonization ends out that we have
created consistent methods of
documentation we have what are called
training standards the training standard
is the tool that we use to document our
our learning processes so for example
each learning topic has a standard
associated with it and this this
training standards should be built on
what is called a verification of
competency document this is our quality
control peace in our program where you
would have a document that would set
minimum criterion for what a trained
person looks like so for example that
you know there would be a set of
learning objectives abbr stablished
upfront and then you would outline what
does it look like to be appropriately
trained the other piece of that is that
then that document becomes kind of the
the building block for creating the
training standard that then says here's
how we're going to train a person to do
it so those are partnered documents that
we hope to develop globally as much as
we can recognizing that there's a lot of
variability in how people are how people
use words and do procedures across our
global systems a really good example of
that is that in our UK programs we've
tried to find consistency in the way
that we administered the the euthanasia
training and what we found is that the
differences in laws and regulations
regarding euthanasia as well as the
terminology was completely different so
we couldn't actually
to really share the learning so our
global team had the responsibility of
finding consistency as much as we could
on kind of core principles and
delivering appropriate training for each
of those sites and that that's what we
aspire to and even making that a little
more complicated is the fact that then
at sites that don't speak English we
have the requirement to translate to
chinese to french into spanish in our
organization so what we are seeking to
find harmonization so the by consistent
methods of documentation by verification
of competency by creation of training
standards as much as we can that are
globally aligned and then our learning
community of practice which will and
will eventually be a group that provides
oversight guidance we're in the process
of creating a guidance document it won't
be an SOP because it's extremely hard to
to audit against a program like this and
to make it inflexible so what we prefer
is that what we prefer is that we
created a guidance document that would
help that set out expectations for our
training programs and I give another
example of this in that some of our
programs didn't actually go through and
verify competency of the staff so they
had a great training program they would
put the staff they would train them and
they would give them a set of like an
assessment checklist so here are the
things you need to do to train and then
the but there was never a final
confirmation that the individual was was
confident they weren't assessed and and
and checked off as somebody who's a
who's competent and especially for
people in the UK right now that's a part
of the new EU directive requirements of
training programs and so we're working
very hard to make sure that our programs
contain verification of competency of
the staff and this is an important thing
in the u.s. too because we ran into some
concerns about the aya cooks knowing for
sure that our people were competent in
the face of a lacking set of training
documents in our investigators space
so we went through and we used a
consultant to provide competency
verification by taking our verification
of competency document and assessing
people skills one on one by one as to
the competency and we also had a quick
turnaround team this is actually Kiana
Graham and Denise holiday that did the
work the actual hands-on operational
work and they they were able to evaluate
the skills and report back to the iock
on what they felt the level of skills
were within the organization within that
sites organization so it was a very
effective way to come back to the I
think I can say we feel confident that
our staff are trained there were a few
individuals that didn't pass their
training criterion and in that case they
were put back through the training
program and you know it's just important
to recognize that that training for
someone who's a new employee our newly
learning is a very different process
than training someone who may have
veered from what was the original rement
of the of the training which does happen
in time as people kind of take shortcuts
and develop their own way to to work ok
Ashley I'm sending it to you so I'd like
to just talk about how we address global
harm is a harmonization of training here
at covance and there are some
similarities with what Marianne
described at GSK and I'd like to start
by talking out talking about our use of
global working groups across our global
company we've done this to establish
consistent training documents when
possible so with these global working
groups what we do is identify
individuals from the various sites to
come together usually by telecon to
discuss different trainings compare how
our sites differ what our expectations
and then where and when we can
standardize those expectations and the
training
so currently i'm leading one of these
global working groups to reformat and
revise and standardize our training on
animal welfare which will be rolled out
this year but i find working across the
globe with our different colleagues at
different sites is a great way to really
understand how they function how they
function within the various differences
in regulations and those types of
requirements and then how can we
function as a global team as one
provance to and then standardized as
much as possible so we also look for
consistent consistency in our methods of
documentation i can mention the floor
with us doing a lot of glp work and
trying to meet those glp requirements a
lot of those regulations are kind of
consistent across site to site but we do
have some some sites that perform more
discovery work so they may not be within
that range of performing work within the
glp environment on a regular basis but
we still want to strive for this
consistent method of documentation again
because it affords us the ability to
ensure that people are receiving
standard training ensure that we have
the ability to document that and show
that to our clients and just maintain
that that piece of information about our
technical staff lastly we really try to
foster open communications between our
local training groups so those core
groups of people in the training the
training group that provide training to
our new trainees and staff as they move
through the organization again working
to maintain consistency I'm also since
we have multiple sites that are
developing different techniques we have
had on site exchange of knowledge
between our groups so for instance if a
if a group in Harrogate has developed a
technique that we're not interested in
employing and our Madison site it would
be pretty common for us to have some of
their their technical staff or those
people that are the subject matter
experts and those techniques to come
over and help us
as we are learning and that way they can
interface with our training group and
our technicians in order to train that
so again we're providing that
consistency amongst the different sites
another great example of this was
utilizing our staff from our münster
germany facility when we were developing
non-human primate developmental and
reproductive toxicology work here in
madison so again we really integrated a
group of their technical staff and
trainers here within our group so that
again there could be this open active
sharing of knowledge and that exchange
to help us get off the ground we really
want to prove that rework and you know
reinventing the wheel if there's another
site that has that expertise and again
we do that here in Madison and there's
if there's expert knowledge here that we
can pass on to our other sites were more
than willing to share that and
facilitate people going there in person
to diffa sylhet 8 that training I think
it's really based on an expectation of
our clientele that you know they do work
here or in Europe or in China they want
to give the same product so it's really
important for us as a business to
maintain this global harmonization of
training to be able to provide that as a
standard to our clients so now I will
pass over to Mary Ann to summarize in ok
Thank You Ashley I just catching up on a
few things that hadn't been able to
share with you because I was I'm
technically inept I just wanted to share
a paper and recognize the work that was
done by excellent group of authors that
are online today and this paper was
published in Jay last November of 2013
and the title is assessment of
proficiency and competency in laboratory
animal bio methodologies it's an
excellent paper that sets out some of
the basic understandings for what
competency and proficiency are and it
really helps us align terminology across
our field such that we can you know
start to speak the same language as a
group of laboratory animal
as a group of laboratory animal
scientists I do find that we have not
developed we know a lot about
environmental Richmond we know a lot
about nutrition we know a lot about
studies and animal models but we don't
seem to have really established as a
field a set of expectations for training
and I see this paper is one step towards
setting out a common way that we can
start talking about training together so
I and I also wanted to indulge that the
ls certification levels are an excellent
way to to set a baseline for knowledge
for our staff so that we know where
they're at in their basic understanding
and then local training programs have
the obligation to train on the other
things that are more specific to the
things that they have needs for hands-on
work and other work-related activities
but the a last certifications are an
excellent way to further our
understanding and baseline knowledge so
with that I did want to just close by
saying that I hope that Ashley and I
have helped you understand some of the
ways that our training programs are
working within our organizations at GSK
and at covance it's been a pleasure
working with Ashley as I've learned a
lot about her training program and had a
chance to understand and I do find that
working across global training programs
with even within jsk there's so much to
learn about how to train and how others
have have so effectively figured out how
to conquer the scope and the breadth of
what training is in our organizations I
hope that we've been able to share a
little bit about training formats which
I do believe is a whole conference in
itself because it's an emerging area
where we're using a lot of new
electronic devices and exciting media
and technology to share ideas and
information we've we've discussed
briefly competency and the importance of
verifying that people are confident
within our organization and and that is
a measure of quality of a training
program itself and that assessing that
and being aware of what the status of
our staff is is an important part of our
training program
also that we that we need to have
qualified trainers and Assessors who can
who can you know probably bring forward
the best way to train people and some
consistency within our programs and and
be really the subject matter experts
because you know I think that by pulling
them in and using their capabilities
many people like to train and they love
to impart their knowledge on other so it
is it builds a culture also of training
we talked about curriculum and how you
pick curriculum and we're currently in
the process of creating curriculum
within our organization and and so
figuring out how will people know where
to go to know what they need to do to be
well trained and then lastly we talked
briefly about global training programs
from the standpoint of our two
organizations and the true richness that
our global understanding global programs
and the global training needs and
sharing information and resources brings
to our organizations so with that all
I'll close our part of the discussion
and open it up for questions okay so I
know there will be questions so I
believe I just shall read them someone
would like to contact me I would welcome
that i can give you my I believe my
email address is in the information but
please do feel free to contact either
Ashley right the next question is how do
you maintain your records of training
for future reference so I can answer
this for myself and pass it to Ashley
but I can tell you that this is actually
a point of serious angst in our
organization because we've selected an
online program and the online program
does a really great job of collecting
information and it's also a way that
people can sign in and sign up for
training it also is a way that they can
be reminded that they need to train for
example we can tell them that they need
to retake the class every three years or
whatever we ask but it's a very
complicated program but that said it is
the commitment
that GSK is made to training
documentation we have historic training
records and some training is not going
to be able to be documented in that
system so it's going to be it's taking
us time we are really refining it right
now Ashley did you want to comment on
that so it looks like there was a
question here on maintaining your
records of training for future reference
and for us and it looks like yeah let's
see training for future reference so for
our glp facility we use a combination of
paper records and binders that are filed
with study data and we also when we
utilize the online training we use that
online program as a means of maintaining
those records for future reference so
again that is within a glp environment
where it's pretty rigorous I would
imagine and what I've experienced it in
more of an academic setting that paper
records in an easily located area so our
central location would be a more common
but perhaps also utilizing you know like
an online system to maintain those
ok so the next question was what is your
um let's see I'm going to answer this
question really quickly because I have
the paper someone asked me for the
authors on the article that I mentioned
and yes I can answer that it was Paula
Clifford Natasha Melfi John Bowe danske
Elizabeth Johnson James killer and
Stefan baron so those were the authors
and then it's in the November issue its
volume 52 number 6 in November of 2013
it's the first article in the journal
and it is a really excellent article and
i've used i distribute it to our
trainers and used it as a way to kind of
find consistency and how we talk about
words very nice ok I had another
question that said how many people were
evaluated by the consultant I have to be
honest with you I'm not sure about those
metrics but I know it was something
above a hundred people and they were
evaluated for all rodent procedures so
it was something that they were required
to do and that Denise and kiana made an
appointment with the people and and work
towards and work towards assessing them
one at a time on their competency in it
there was some painfulness in that
process it was not an easy thing to do
so you know it was required that they
had to make a time and show that they
were confident let's see okay this
question and I let me just make sure if
I understand it and I'm gonna pass it to
okay this is a question for Ashley let
me see if I can get Ashley to answer
this one okay and let me pass this on to
Ashley and then another question coming
in for me from paola it says what
criteria are methods do you use to
ensure consistent assessment when
observing the techniques being performed
how do you know if they are being not
being performed properly who does the
assessments is it usually the training
staff or dedicated Assessors so again
kind of getting back to that making sure
that our assessment is consistent when
we go and look at staff so as I
mentioned typically all our assessments
are done by a couple of different people
so initial competency assessments are
done by the core training group of
individuals these people have been
trained both on the techniques and our
highly proficient and really subject
matter experts in those techniques and
those are the people that would be doing
those initial competency assessments and
then for the next step which is kind of
the proficiency assessments that's done
on a regular basis with a training group
with supervisors and managers and also
our QA Department that are within the
facility so there's kind of a constant
ongoing method of checks of of technical
staff abilities and these again are
unannounced so it's not that our staff
can really prepare for them or know that
they're going to be assessed it's just a
regular expectation for our managers and
our supervisors to be going back through
and assessing those techniques being
performed so again we look for that
technique is it from being performed
correctly or not and if it's not then we
take additional measures on top of that
so we have done some assessment of our
trained core training group by the
veterinarians and have really found that
are our core training group is highly
skilled we've never identified as a
veterinary team that there are
deficiencies and our actual trainers
that are the ones that are performing
the training for our technical staff in
general and so we are quite lucky in
that regard but there is also that you
know kind of fall back assessment of the
trainer's through the veterinary team
and again we're out and looking at the
techniques of the technical staff are
performing as well so that would be
another measure of of observing and
ensuring a consistent assessment across
the groups so it looks like there is
another question for that Maryann can
answer here okay so we have another
question from Claudia Yale she said 400
or so staff that were assessed by the
consultant for all rodent procedures
approximately how many one-on-one visits
were needed per person I know that they
usually scheduled time for these people
in in blocks and in that it was quite a
while that it took to work through these
you know because they had the standards
available to them and then they worked
through each of the procedures and so it
was about a hour and a half a two hour
time frame that they had blocked out for
each person so they work through this
one by one by one okay let's see I'm
just checking for questions
let's see can you please supply the
author's names okay we got that one
sorry about that i think that i might
have answered all the incoming questions
are there any other questions okay so if
there are no other questions I believe
that we've finished our seminar and I
thank you for attending and look forward
to hearing from any of you that would
like to share what you're doing so that
we can extend this community of people
that are involved in training